two Las Vegas police officers being
recognized for going above and beyond
the Call of Duty 8 News now's Brian will
in The Newsroom after attending the
recognition ceremony Brian yeah Metro
officers Kyle Johnson and Kabir Campbell
two relatively new officers to the force
went out of their way to help a family
in need
we're just out here trying to help
people we both looked at each other that
you know that night and just thought we
could help someone else out so we did
these two officers say they were just
doing their job one night when they got
a call to come to mandolin Bay a woman
needed assistance and was trying to
escape a domestic violence situation
they had no place to go so instead of
them being out in the cold with the sick
sick little girl we just you know we
talked with them figured out what's
going on and we just helped them in the
best way we could they did more than
just help both officers paid for the
family of Four's two-night stay at the
hotel it's our job to show up and do
what we can to make sure that they're
safe and sound and that's all we did for
that family it wasn't anything out of
the ordinary for us in recognition of
their efforts Tom Kovac with the LV MPD
Foundation gave these officers the first
good ticket Awards of 2023. this good
ticket program gives us the opportunity
to highlight those good deeds and
hopefully uh
you know shows our appreciation Resorts
World donated a two-night stay at their
hotel along with dining experiences for
both officers and their families both
officers just say they were doing their
job it does motivate me to continue
being the you know humble and and
look to do the best thing for people I
was just being myself and wanted to help
out others
now the lfvmpd foundation plans to
continue the good ticket program
honoring officers every month for their
Good Deeds